un cabinet ministériel délocalisé à
saint quentin en yvelines
marlène schiappa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes s'installent à trappes durant
trois jours 3 que ce qu'on ressort c'est
que il ya une vraie richesse attrape
d'initiative et un esprit très
accueillants sincèrement mon agent
m'avait déconseillé d'aller à trappes
avec les clichés négatifs qui peuvent
être véhiculés sur la ville au contraire
moi je vois des gens qu'il faut
énormément de choses qui se bougent
qu'ils prennent des initiatives
le territoire yvelinois est
régulièrement visité par les ministres
ceux de la cohésion des territoires à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la ministre des
affaires européennes à bazoches sur
guyonne david douillet quitte la
présidence des républicains des yvelines
il a annoncé arrêter la politique
à l'issue de son mandat de conseiller
régional en 2021
des fiançailles a raté nos repas et
coignières n'envisageait pas un tel
scénario
le 9 avril les deux communes annoncent
leur volonté de fusionner un projet
dénoncé par les oppositions municipales
et des citoyens après un mois houleux
la décision tombe le 7 mai la fusion est
enterré
peut-être un peu d'incompréhension et
notamment sur les études
puisqu'aujourd'hui s'agissait que d'
études il y a que des études qui ont été
présentées en conseil municipal
il était dit que la fusion serait votée
le 2 mai il en a jamais été question
une nouvelle tête du côté de la
préfecture des yvelines serge morvan
nommé commissaire général à l'égalité
des territoires
c'est jean jacques brot qui s'installe à
versailles du côté scolaire l'heure est
au changement à elancourt l'école
regarde vers le futur
au revoir tables et chaises alignées la
circulation des élèves et favoriser un
projet nommé bouge ta classe en juin du
nouveau pour les rythmes scolaires de
septembre 2018
90% des communes choisissent de revenir
à la semaine de quatre jours est des
retours et des premières après plusieurs
mois d'étude la racine la monnaie locale
de la vallée de chevreuse a été mise en
circulation en juin une monnaie
utilisable à son lancement dans une
vingtaine d'établissements des premières
aussi dans le sport avec le semi
marathon de la ville de trappes 168
coureurs étaient au départ on avait un
besoin un amant qui existait sur cette
ville c'est que les trappistes couraient
tous individuellement mais ne se
retrouver jamais
ensemble pour une course unique pour
qu'on a choisi de l'organiser cette
année elle répond à un vrai besoin est
des saint quentinois champion des
yvelines les basketteurs norvégien de
moins de 13 ans remporte le championnat
façon chez mais les mortuaciens sont
moins chanceux en football pour la coupe
des yvelines seniors c'est cuit en cours
qui s'imposent e viser la coupe du monde
les bleus s'entraînaient pour la
dernière fois en public à clairefontaine
avant de s'envoler pour la russie où ils
seront sacrés de quoi ravir les
supporters et pas seulement verbale
agents nés de la gamme
l'accueil est toujours extraordinaire et
puis on est on est là pour la france
quant à elle soutenu
non on est soutenus nous avons quoi
voilà toujours un peu je rencontre les
supporters on passe un bon moment avec
eux ça me permet de voir tout ce qui
peut manquer d'argent en cyclisme le
mois de juin 2018 rimer avec champions
et anniversaire les meilleurs coureurs
tricolores se sont affrontés à mantes la
jolie à l'occasion des championnats de
france elle la revanche un fêter son
vingtième anniversaire plus de 160
coureurs se sont alignés au départ c'est
cinq fois plus que lors de la première
édition
c'est une tradition c'est c'est
l'histoire de saint quentin en yvelines
l'histoire de cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et accueil vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi de ah
koon d'elancourt un anniversaire aussi à
thoiry en 1968 paul de la panouse
construit un circuit safari cinquante
ans plus tard plus de 750 animaux sont
présentés eux auront travaillé deux ans
de la découverte de la musique classique
aux neuf mois de répétitions sur scène
les artistes amateurs et professionnels
de génération lully ou créer une oeuvre
est ce qui fait l'actualité peut parfois
être insolite le vélodrome nationale a
été le théâtre d'une compétition inédite
extraction chalenge avec 19 équipes de
pompiers venus de toute la france